what about this Grimace Shake syrup the
McDonald's website lists several
ingredients but offers no clue as to
where the syrup comes from or why it's
called a Grimace Shake syrup that's when
I realized the answer has been there all
along Grimace is the embodiment of a
milkshake though others still insist
he's a taste bud maybe that's because
he's Bal he is the taste bud of a living
milkshake he likes milkshakes they
literally inflate his mass and keep him
healthy and he likes tasting everything
around him not only does this explain
the tweets but it also explains why some
of the videos show consumers reacting
poorly to the shakes because they're
literally consuming Grimace matter and
some of the videos show Grimace coming
after them he simply wants to steal the
shakes just as he had as evil Grimace
way back at the very beginning but with
the success of the Grimace shake and
Grimace now out in the loose rampaging
in public it'll be interesting to see
what becomes of Grimace next year on
Grim's birthday